From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
We're rolling.
Alright, you want to start?
Yep.
You ready?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Great.
So this is the 11th.
Okay, so Marker.
Today is Thursday, April 11th, 2013.
We are in Los Angeles, California, recording on behalf of the Southern oral history program at UNC Chapel Hill.
The Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
The interviewer today is David Klein.
Our videographer is John Bishop and we are here with Mr. Ben Caldwell.
Thank you very much for agreeing to be part of our project.
Well, excited about the prospects of this museum in Washington, D.C.
I lived there for about three years and taught it Howard and worked at the Smithsonian with Bernice Reagan in them and got to Mr. Ellen Lomax at our house and talk about the blues with a good friend of mine who
was Mr. Barlow, Dr. Barlow, who was the doctor of the blues, WPFW.
And so he used to have that every night.
So he would bring through all these phenomenal blues musicians and people.
So I felt pretty blessed and I was able to put my ethnographic hat on.
You know, it really meet a lot of people in those ways.
So it was really pretty fun and fun time in my life.
How long did you work on the museum?
Yes, I met worth long.
Now Mr. Worth long and then I met in Philadelphia and also in Flaherty Film Seminars.
And I got to see the land where the blues was born and was really blown away by it because it was, you know, I'm from New Mexico.
And so my father was a, I'm a foreman on the train line.
And so I was around a lot of that work music that you guys documented in the land where the blues was born.
So just that lining up the trains and then just in including all that kind of stuff that was the environmental sounds with your music itself was really showed in me.
Because that's the work, the kind of world I was around as a kid.
So to start out with my life, my grandfather and my mom and a whole family set were migrant farmers.
And my grandfather was a kind of a lighter skinned black man and he could glass as a Latino when he wanted to.
He worked in Mexico, Texas, Oklahoma, New Mexico, Arizona.
And then their migratory parent was always that following the lines to Bakersfield here.
Where was he born or was he born?
Texas. Texas was the part of the life that there were from.
And they traveled with it. It was two men and a woman and they could do everything. They could build houses.
I was very empowered with my grandfather's capacity to do things and he had never even, he didn't even have a formal education.
He bought up a lot of property in the town that he settled in.
And the only reason he settled this is tent burned down.
They had to stay there in that town and they figured out how to make it work.
And so a lot of my grandfather I find as I get older is a lot in me.
Because he was my babysitter and he was a power broker.
Because I remember walking behind him meeting the mayor.
I had real clear access to going to City Hall and just walking there as a baby.
I can just still, you know, like just so that whole part of a small town and accessibility and things like that.
I was able to see. Also the academy, my grandfather was a projectionist.
And he projected in a town that had the Latino separated from the whites.
So there was a Latino theater that he projected at and then he would run across the street and then project the white theater.
And then there was a specific place at the time where blacks only kind of had to be at the top in the balcony.
And then there was a lot of work in the community.
There was a lot of work in the community.
And I started doing research the last few years of my life.
These last few years.
It's been really interesting to deal with the concept of that town because it was name dimming.
And the Crocker family made the woman who married them.
Her maiden name was dimming.
And dimming in Mexico was the border between Mexico and the US before the Guadalupe Hildalgo.
So I was so our part of that world was quite unique.
So it was Guadalupe Hildalgo. It was the last main land part of the United States that came in.
And that Pancho vía, Geronimo, Cochise, the Butterfield Trail.
All those things kind of ran through our town, which is pretty interesting.
And that it was airplanes were first used in war, general purging.
You had to think of this sort of a border place where things are influxing.
Being defined in that way at an influx.
I think so because I was at the crux of a crazy place of change.
And there was a lot of stories.
It was just a whole lot of stories.
If we just went out in Boy Scouts, the stories where these Indian,
so our guy was almost my scout master was like a nephanographic study.
He was geologists and waste because he would go out and he was like,
this is where the Cochise and the military would fight at this pass.
And so I dream about it.
And then this is the way that Geronimo was able to live in the desert
because we had those types of things around this.
And so there was a bunch of people who were like,
you know, Pancho Villa and Zapata were the Latino people that they really liked him a whole lot.
And so there was, and then my grandfather was a baseball fanatic.
And so he had a colored team.
So he had Indians, Asians, blacks, all plain throughout the Southwest as a baseball team.
So there was that kind of bomb storming.
That kind of environment.
So yeah.
They played against other colored groups.
There was this whole circuit that they had that were semi-professionals.
And it was a part of the before they became, you know, when they were really segregated.
So it was the tail end of all that segregated time period that I was able to see.
That's fast and absolutely fast.
And this would be throughout the Southwest.
Yeah, because I see my grandfather's pattern would be Texas up to northern New Mexico.
And then what would be Eastern Arizona?
So that was their plain pattern.
And they had their own designations of what the different levels were.
And then after some of our guys would then go to the semi-pro leagues and then, you know,
kind of work themselves up.
And it was fun to watch them pretty famous.
They were famous within their own world.
Coming in after church, someone would be dressed up in a suit still.
Because they're late on time, you know, late before, but the game got started.
Just be like the pitcher.
I remember the pitcher coming out with this tie on, tucking it around his neck,
and then coming like throwing the shit so hard.
It was just a kind of a fun environment to see these men.
The other part of my life that was interesting is really to me is that I was a designated driver for my grandfather.
My father was an interesting man because he was a foreman.
That's how he got to New Mexico.
And he was a highly intelligent man.
He was born in Des Moines, Iowa.
His family was middle-class. He went to church.
He went to Catholic schools and all that.
He got all the way up to college and went to what is it?
Marquette University.
So he was that kind of a cat and living in that type of a world,
which was, you know, with mostly migrant folks and, you know, kind of pioneering types.
People who migrated to New Mexico were people who were just pioneers.
You know, they just went out and struck out on their own.
And so I got to see the blues being made in just by just really everyday people, you know.
So got to see that and was really pretty impressed.
And storytellers, I got to meet some really phenomenal storytellers,
the ones that did the signifying monkeys and all that kind of stuff.
And got to hear that live and well and was really blown away with it as a kid.
Because I remember trying to describe it, but then the closest I could come was, you know,
that one that Disney did with Uncle, that's what Uncle Remus said.
But these cats were like, they would drink and, you know, like, grab a rattlesnake.
And really I saw a guy grab a rattlesnake and kill the motherfucker while he was telling the story.
So it was that kind of realness around my life, you know.
So he's telling signifying monkey and then this sidewinder comes up and then he's like, grabs it and then like,
and then he is a kid. I was like, how fantastic.
That's a storytelling and half there.
But in the railroad line.
And that was the other thing I looked up in my life.
I lived some of my formal life in the boxcar.
So it was kind of like a boxcar.
I remember having those first steps that made a metal, you know, grabbing my arms,
going up the chair, up to get into the boxcar.
And pretty impressed about, you know, so that was part of my life.
So that's the early life and then you said you were designated driver for my dad.
Yeah, that was by the time I turned 16.
But I think that the whole thing on silver rights, the thing that I really,
in New Mexico, it was a cuss, a real cuss, cuss, but change there.
Because at that time, like I was saying, they had things that were still segregated
because the Latinos had their thing and then there was whites and blacks together on the theater level.
And what just interrupt, what year were you born?
In 1945.
1945. So we're talking about when you were saying that those times.
In the 1950s, early 50s from 45.
Yeah, because it was like, since he was, I would, he babysitted me for the early parts of my life.
So I would say from 1945, until 1955, is where I spent the greater part of like kicking it with him in part in 10 years, you know, for those 10 years.
And then later our family still got engaged with the theater because then my grandfather then projected for the drive in movies.
So he was a part of that too.
And so we could go and see those. So I was always around the kind of movie world and all its manifestations, you know.
Never thought it would be a part of my life.
So just the whole thing of how it happened to me later.
But let's see.
So school.
My first days of school were really, pretty interesting because I had learned to actually, I was a pretty free running kid because it was a free space.
And so the first days of school, I really, when they had recess and things, I disappeared.
And so, and then they found out that I was leaving and going home because I was like, why is everybody sleeping?
I'm not sleeping. So I'm like, I'll just go. And so I just went and went home.
And so they discovered that I was going.
And so I stayed my first recess was after I'd been in school for about a week or two.
And then all the kids all sudden noticed that I was there because they had done this kind of.
What did they call it when they cut places up and only make it like they had the Latinos all in one school and segregated the place.
And so, and then they made Smith school only for white.
And I happened to be one block on this side of the track. It's to the one block on the other.
And so I showed up in school. We kind of white freak them out.
And so the whole.
In all white school. So I was the only white person in all white school.
And it happened through just the line I happened to be on one side of the railroad track instead of this.
And so when I showed up, the school freaked out.
And, and the kids started throwing rocks at me and throwing dirt and just being pretty just like living their parents life on me.
And, and so I, I then ran. And then later I'd learn to fight for myself because my, my, my cousin was watching me.
And he looked at me kind of like evilly like, what, you know, just running from these.
You know how to fight. We touchy out of box and stuff.
So I just turned around. And then the funniest thing I still remember is that they says,
oh, you fight like me and you kick like a Mexican.
I said, definitely what come with it.
And so from then on, I was a jock. I learned how to play football. And I would run over all those kids that, that, that really met me harm.
And so, and I found out how to do it with gusto. And, and I became a jock.
And so my next 12 years was really pretty cool in, in, in New Mexico.
Did that earn you some sort of status or respect?
Very much so. The whole thing. Even throughout because you know it's pioneered pioneering people and they ride horses and, and bronco bulls.
And the whole way that they lived was very rough and ready. And, and I like those guys. You know, they were fun friends of ours.
And my grandfather was a, was a, you know, a bramable. He liked the bramables and all that whole world.
And so we'd watch that. So we had friends that were in the kind of cowboy rodeo world too.
But, and, but with those folks, we just found the same thing. I had to teach my brothers the same thing as they grew up.
Is that, you know, as long as you stood up for yourself, they respect you.
And so, that was the thing that each of them. And so it was funny. My youngest one we were talking about it as I grew up.
Maybe we should, is, it's all the door.
Okay. Let me just talk.
We're going again.
Okay.
Okay. I guess I was just talking about that early life of mine.
And, I mean, where, where there are other black families in the town?
Yeah, there was about 150 blacks in the town on a constant basis.
And they were mostly migrant people, really wonderful people, very down the earth.
They treated my family really well.
I've always got, we always got a kind of a real, people treated us nice all of our family, you know, like the black people.
You know, like the black neighborhoods really treated us really like royal. They treated us very nice, you know.
They like my father. He was highly intelligent man. We were a whole family.
And, and we're proud family.
Oh, that sounds like a serious wreck.
I'll just start with after that was kind of like my child life.
And then I'm asking one more question.
Sure.
You started to talk about passing these lessons on to your brothers.
Right.
And with my brothers, what was interesting is like each of them had to deal with this idea of the pioneering white man.
And then you know, how do you deal with that and their idea of what a black male is, you know.
And so part of what we, my father taught first was the sense of pride.
And you all stand up for each other and kind of thing.
And then my sister, we had one sister too. And she was the same kind of person.
So we didn't stand for the inward. It was like you say it.
And you, your head was off. You know, that was our first concept.
And my father was very much that type of a person. He really did not like cow-tailing to people because of race.
He didn't stand for it a little bit. And he didn't want us to ever be that kind of a person.
So that was the way we were taught. It's like you're a man just like everybody else.
And that really helped us a lot in pioneering towns.
So then you had to keep proving that.
Well, you only have to do it per generation.
It's like they'll test a call the well the next one and see if you stand up like your brother did and stuff like that.
And then the process of if they did whip you, then they had to deal with your other brothers.
a thing is part of what we had as a family, a group of boys and girl because my sister
was as strong as any of the guys that were around.
And so for instance my brother and I were talking and I was like, because I got drafted.
So my youngest brother was like four or five years old when I first, well no he was about
eight, nine, ten years old.
And then so when I came back he was about to go to junior high to college and I mean high
school in those days.
And so anyway so I was not around his life for about eight years and so he came and lived
with me in DC and so we were just discussing you know, how did you deal with that incident
when you had to deal with the cowboys you know, so and because they would so he was like,
oh yeah that was a time when we went you know because what would happen is they would go
to the dry river bed and have kegs of beer and it was like around you know really a lot
of fun and people just had fun and so he found himself in the middle of all that and he's
like then they all turned and he's like oh there's a and he was like oh we're going to
go ass you look kind of thing and so he's like I said well then what did you do?
He says I looked at the biggest one and I said I'm gonna I'm gonna knock the fuck out
of him and if it if he doesn't fall I'm gonna run.
He says thank God I hit him and he he fell down and they're like oh you're a good man
here you want a damn beer you know and that's the and that was just the way our life was
you had to really stand up for yourself and and and prove it you know and then people
really respect you after that so that was just an example.
Another is this like the difference between the two worlds is like when some of my brothers
came to see me here in California they don't they have a different way that police deal
with you you know and and so I told them they had to really really chill so they left you
know because they really left and went back home and then when they were home one you
would die yeah I would die they would kill you you know and so I was like you better
just really chill when you're here and so they they moved back home and so when they
went went back home one of the cops from New Mexico jumped on on Michael who's this he's
one of my brothers that don't really stand for any kind of shit and so they were going
up side his head with a stick and then my sister grabbed the police and then attacked the police
and they both beat him up and you know and and but in our hometown because of how we were
respected we knew the judge the judge then talked to them and says come on these guy went to school
with with them and you know it's so you know so they just balanced out so whereas if it was here
they would have been dead or in prison still you know and so that's just the and so in that town
we could live just like normal people because it was a normal I mean what I mean by normal is nobody
gets anything over anybody but it if you if you're if you treat everybody right you can be treated
just like a regular American without that kind of onus that ends up because I would have normally
messed up our family forever because all the two of them would have been in prison
right that's not the same that race isn't there oh no it was still there and it would have and
two other black kids it's there you know but if you if but for our family because of how we
treated everybody and how we were respected it we we were able to pass through through that because
you know there were other kids that are that would have that if they had had done the same thing
yeah they would have been prison because they were black but we were lucky enough for some reason
to to be respected enough to have that as a foible and so as so I thought that was a very good
example now we were as a family and respected in that town and then you carried that with you when
you went on to college throughout the world yes from then on because even when I was in the army
so that was when I first left home I'll tell the pictures better and this is when I and it has
a little bit of music because it works better for me and so this is my mom and dad and then these
early pictures of me and my brothers the four big ones as we call ourselves and so I first started
video my first deals were there this is me as a young man in Vietnam and so I started and that
these are their first photographs that I ever took as a kid you know the 21 year old and and so
after being in that whole film world the thing that was yeah well I had um
about six months in art school I was it went to Arizona School of Art and they drafted me out of
the art school because it was an art school not a four year school and so I was at a Disney
school there in Arizona and then this is picture of my sister and I went came back and just started
shooting my family and in the Arizona environment and the black people that were in it and so I thought
that I would make that my job is to really see and because I was noticing the the tonalities and
the sense of color and the skin the self-portrait of of of our skin was similar to the earth that was
in the desert and our skin rolled up like the bushes and so there was a kind of an interesting
look that our skin had in relationship and statistically in black and white so I started playing
around with the images in that manner and yeah this is right after Vietnam did the Vietnam
response you were thinking the way they in terms of looking at the world how you look at the world?
I it made me not look at the world with a veil you know that veil pulled what's pulled off
and my religious of religiousness disappeared too because because at that time um
they asked us to kill people the you know the preachers they were like and I asked them
straight ahead you just like it's all right to kill they're like yeah I'm like down
it's like I don't know if I like you guys anymore because you you you're not saying what we were
taught you know and you know do on to Caesar the things that are Caesar and this is Caesar's
shit you know and things to God is positive things and so and I got to also see in the war zone
that there were real humans there you know and we were only able to kill them because we made
them the other and I saw a lot of similarities with the other and me you know and I was the other
in United States and they're having me chase down others over here and the the yeah and those
Vietnamese ladies young young women they kind of were following me it was weird because I would
see them in a lot of different places and it was you know that they were like two of them in
each picture and it was it took me out how each place and and then they would say Ben I know you
you know so it fucked with me as a 21 year old I don't know what in the world you guys how can
you know me I just met me you know but they're like I know you okay and they were fun they were
mountain yards and mountain yards are the black people of that world so it was kind of interesting
to see that the other thing politically I I got to see I read Malcolm X there and I saw a lot
of similarities between his life and mine because he was raised in the southwest and he had that
clan thing around him and all the kinds of strife and tribulations like even his dad my dad
was that kind of a person even though he wasn't a Garvey that he was really definite revolutionary
in the sense of fighting for his life and and I and that always has bothered me when you were
proud of yourself that that's just considered revolutionary you know and so that's the kind of
dichotomy to me is like I I've never understood that why me being prideful of my family and the
people I'm from but not to the point that it's arrogance just pride you know that that scene
is being militant because that's something that I've always been it's just prideful I don't hate
one culture over the other I can get along with them but I feel I'm equal to any other culture
that meets me you know and I can point to my bad sides and I can point to our high sides two of the
high cultures that we've created and things that we're apart it it may not be here now but it was
a part of the culture and it meant and it meant a lot to the cultures that he emulated you know
and so that's the way I see it you know so I've never and my family is always pushed just like
that you know it's just you know you you know be prideful of who you are and carry yourself in a
manner therefore you know so what was the world of the army like the army well yeah it was
interesting for me because I'm I have a New Mexico accent which is a non-exant you know it doesn't
it's a non-identifiable accent so to fall in amongst a bunch of blacks who are from the south
then they were like where are you from man I'm like and I would say Mexico is all Mexican all right
yeah so I mean it was that kind of way and I had a Mexican accent because I I did have a little
carriage of Mexican language syntax in me at that time because I was mostly around Latinos so
so I had that and and a little Spanish little Spanish in my language too you know so but anyway
yeah it was pretty it was I was another person I don't like being trapped you know and they trapped
me you know and so I was not a nice guy you know I was pretty angry and trapped and I got to see how
I would have been if I had been in slate I was really not good and so but yeah the army when
they you know they drafted me and then they forced me I thought I was going to be able to get out
of it because I had trick knees and but they wanted me to operate on it and all they could do in
those days is exploratory surgery and I was like game hell no I'm not going to be explored on
because I like my torn tent pig ligaments I they'll patch up and heal themselves you know
and so what do I have to do that and that was my young self-fighting for my my body at that time
because and so you know in my home when I was in the military my knee went out and so I saw
that as a godson and I used it as a way to get out of nom and so I got out of nom and I I really
pushed them and I ran into a real nice physician that looked at me and asked me how was I walking
and put me and made me an ambulatory patient from that point on and so then they shipped me to Japan
and I got to see Japan and then while I was in Japan the thing that I noticed with myself is I
wanted to know who the power was what what who was the power they got my ass into this you know
and so when I was there they I was there in October and so Thanksgiving happened and then the
American ambassador had an open invitation to some of the veterans I mean some of the the soldiers
who were there and everybody said hell no I'm not playing the ambassador I'm like I want to talk
to him so I went there as a young man and got to eat Thanksgiving dinner with the American ambassador
and talked to them about the issues of the war and what things were about and learned a whole lot
and so I like that so much that when it came up to to to to have Christmas dinner with the
with the general of our base I did that too and so I jumped on that and he happened to be one of
the guys that was over the whole theater before before the the guy Westmoreland and so I got to sit
down and talk with him over things you know Christmas dinner and it got me from being sent to
Vietnam on Christmas because I had built myself up so well that they they shipped me back to now
because I refused to have them operate on me and then I built my body up so well that they like
oh you're well enough to be killed again and so they shipped me back over there but then all of
that education that I got with the general and with the ambassador I put it to work in Vietnam
on figuring out how bureaucracies work and so when the bureaucracy I noticed only
new me when I told them that I was there I didn't tell them I was there until they knew I was there
you know I'm saying so because they put you in shit and do it until they until your records came
like oh I'll just I'll be at the end of the line and I'll wait until they say Ben called well
and then otherwise I'll just get to know this base and get to know the people that are on the
base so I got to meet a lot of the hip musicians that were in the base and then when Bob Hoke came
I could go to his set up and you know I just started going to those kinds of things until my
right records came and then once my records came then they shipped me back to my unit and my unit
they were crazy they they had made them worry every day that 10,000 NBA were about to kill their ass
and that was what I that was how I left what I left under that stress and then came back three
months later and they were super stressed out honey lack of sleep and just really weren't thinking
right you know and then the Teto fans have had happened at around the same time so I was there for
the TET and then and then we did something that was a little revolutionary be in that case is
because we had we were we had noticed that there was an old man there and so we pulled him in
and when we pulled him in we were talking okay now we can just pull out because now you can
drop an A-POM on the village you know because there's just this this one guy and then when he
heard that he jumped out of our our our APC and then ran and they told us to kill him you know
and then I aimed at his legs and missed him and then he came back and brought his whole family
and then the whole village walked out with us and then they said okay we'll call it off
it was like educational because we were so happy that we did that because we ended up pulling
almost 150 people out out of there behind our tracks so those were interesting things you know
in the sense of kids learning you know and that so and then I I I stopped engaging the war I
figured out that war is only works if you do something you know so I started figuring out how
to be a pacifist in a war zone you know and and I just refused to kill just for in you know I
would do it if something was for saving me but under that whole thing and that was really
educational for me because it was the first time I I could see that you know that you really
always have a choice you know was that person or did that also involve telling people about the
stance that you made it was just I I didn't I just did it because it was survival you know I was
surviving in the way that I saw fit that would make Ben feel all right after all this and and
that was kind of all I was thinking I didn't want to have any kind of grit grit to it is ideas in
my brain about something that I did in the fit of anger and lack of focus you know did you see it go
another way for others oh yeah it was easy to do that way because you're just so pissed off and
you make the other the other as opposed to and and so I really learned a lot by that and so when
I came out of the military I started just studying people and working and we I did this serious of
work of just off my family and also being truthful with myself on what I saw because I didn't see
in black I didn't see in grays and and other colors I wanted to bring in brilliance and color
and swass of the paint and it's even stronger than what what was on within the camera so I added to
that you know so I used an additive paints to to all my work and I also focused on the whole idea
of the black body you know in specifically a woman's body but but mostly black bodies and dealt
with the gradations of those in the desert and that made it possible well I sent that series to
to join to for my master's degree at UCLA and they loved them and so I got a full ride and then I
got to hang out with these guys so before before that you went to Arizona State yeah Arizona State
was an interesting trip for me because I weren't first went to PCC Phoenix College and then
Phoenix College I was a jock I was a I first played and so I I wanted to prove to myself that I
could be a full back and make it because I was dreaming about it when I was in the military so I
came back and dealt with it but I also was a different kid because I saw in theory or already
when they would try to make me less than who I am and in football it's really rampant you know so
I didn't do well with being called boy jump on this and boy run up there and so I was like I
you know I don't want to drop this ball so I'm not gonna just before I pick it up you kick it
and then tell me to jump on it and then bring it back to you and then call me boy in the same
process I'm just I don't want to be full that that you know so I made it through to the
non-earned area like oh you think you're a badass you think you can't be treated like everybody else
and all this stuff and I'm like I'm not trying to say just treat me like I need to be treated
to just say hi Ben you don't have to add anything else to it you know you don't have to add
and as long as you do that I'm cool with you but any of these added that you add to it it doesn't
work for me and so we would get into it like that but I made the team and then I I was kind of
they kind of like that bite in you as a football player and then I wanted to Arizona state and so
I got a little accepted into that and then I got out of it so because I knew I had bad knees and
I thought that I would be a cripple older person right yeah so it's like do I want to be a
cripple older person for my pride of manhood or do I want to go into something that I really like
so I went into economics and I didn't like that because I it wasn't real because I started asking
questions about the depression and then I was saying these numbers that were studying here
didn't predict the depression but you're still using it as a as a mainframe for studying
depressions so what does that mean you know it's really very confusing to me he says well there's
a economics has its own superstition and life has its own then I'm like then why am I doing this
you know because I'm not studying anything to do with reality so it didn't make any sense to me so
I then went back to I focused on still photography and and then I also took something that was very
a very unusual class that you Arizona State had and it was revolutionary philosophy so I liked
philosophy and we had a a Russian revolutionary kind of one of those agents from Russia that the
undercover like the CIA yeah well they had a KGB guy teaching that class because he was he had
defected from the communist party and he was teaching this class in at Arizona State
I was like I found it out and then he ended up being my buddy so we would talk about all the
different revolutions and the one thing I saw in that that kind of as super impressed me even more
as I've gotten older is the artist in all of those revolutions were it's able to make it through
every step of a revolution because of they were dealing with art and not politics and so
that's something that I would just like you know last week I was in Chicago and I said that
I'm like I'm I'm not political I'm an artist you know I says because I want the thing that I
found is I'm getting older that politicians stop people from communicating with other people that
are other than themselves so if you're a Muslim I mean if you're Republican then don't talk to a
Democrat if you're a Muslim you don't talk to a Christian but if an artist I can culturally work
with whoever and I found that out even more so when I taught at Cal Arts more recently because I
even had Nazis in my class from Germany you know who believe in real fascism and but as an artist
we can communicate because it's about an art form that's within that manure that I don't necessarily
like or understand but we can discuss things in an artistic manner and just like Lenny Riffen's style
you know I like the hell out of her work but I don't like what she was pushing you know or telling
the story of but man did she do a good job you know and so that's the kind of thing that I think
we as artists have a kind of a thing that's outside that that thing and so so that's really
on a philosophical political thing been called well as a 65 year old that's the thing that I've
discovered you know and and having a business and and and done business and like in Cuba done
business and and and places that are hot spots I found that when I go there as an artist that I
don't have to worry about people and and the politics because even when we were going to Cuba we
went to people people exchange and I went there spiritually with with the yoga teachers you know
and we dealt with it like that and and even with them it's an interesting way to enter a society
as a spiritual person you know because you get to see things in a way that other people don't so
I got to go to Ghana and to to Cuba in that manner and then it was really a hell of a good way to go
did it as documentary so.
Right.
Put it at the end of the day and me it's just going to ask me you know at the end of the day is
it is still a political act whether you want it to be or not.
Well because the way other people use it.
Well it's interesting I I just know that you're alignment with the politicians when you even
with how I'm having to run my business here if the consulmans the all of them run it doesn't matter
who the guy is or the woman is who's the politician at the time they're only going to be here four
to eight years I don't have to be here forever so if I align with these different alignments what I
do is have them both in the house and have all the you know be a media person just like television just
have everybody have their form when the police attack after that we did several events with
people who rented the place who did anti police things and the police found out about it and they're
like I thought we had an understanding I don't like the understanding is what I'm going to still
rent this place to people who want whoever wants to say something if it's a Nazi they can rent it
you know I don't care as long as they're not putting down people or wanting to kill them I'm just
wanting to to have everybody say there's peace just like TV does you know oh this is it right
here I'll show you now can I give you a copy of that file so I can concentrate on you but no I
have that the way I yeah I have it as a quick time file if that's what you okay so this is a
documentary done with one of my students she did it on on the whole idea of what we're doing here
and and here is where oh this is chaos network and I named this place chaos network out of the
whole idea of computers because they use this computer math is chaos naferi
so as it said you know he they attacked a media classroom you know just and what what happens with
my classes is I I I I started when I first came back to Los Angeles because I left on going on
film tours with my films and then I taught it Howard for three years and and so I came back with
that kind of an understanding and then I wrote a grant to be an artist in the community and I
happen to be one of the first video artists to get it in the state where we because of my little
master's degree and my past Howard experience they were able to make it where I could teach and work
with the community and so I put this this package together where it was like what Shirley Clark
had taught us about using media in a real democracy way so we let the kids play with the cameras handle
the cameras of power so they could see that they could be a part of it so and then I'd have them
shoot us and then we shoot them and then just get them to relax around the whole medium so that
was what my workshops were is just really get close to this medium you can handle it see your
face on a big screen all of that and Shirley believed that the camera and the television was
like a dancers fourth wall you know where they can because when you watch yourself on television you
kind of adjust your your posture and you watch your addiction and there's a whole thing that
happens when you know that you're being documented and you see it at the same time it kind of it
causes you to tweak yourself you know and so I use that as a tweaking as opposed to me telling them
you know you're slapping down you know they know what it looks like so they look at themselves
and you know I think it's posed for it and you know just give the camera it's due and that helps
them with their their sense of posture who they are is an adult growing into an adult model thing so
I would pop through a lot of kids just that way is just like pop them on the screen have them say
them say who they are what you're about do it with authority and and I would go through whole classes
like that you know just like and that was when cameras and television and all that wasn't in their
environment so I use that as the first step of trying to emancipate the this is when when you
started and if you could also tell me just a little bit about like what age here if you work with
the person this what part of what's in yeah I was in Watts yeah so when I first came in it was
a Watts towers and I was with working with a phenomenal man by the name of John Adubridge and John
was a phenomenal artist and and kind of cultural activator that makes good things happen in this
town he's he's really really fantastic he's from Chicago musician artists sculptor a lot of
just things he could reprocess his junk and metal into making them like animate objects that almost
seem like they walk and move their spirit there's a lot of bridge John Adubridge yeah and yeah if
you guys aren't tapping him you should definitely do something with him because he ran then
communicated arts academy which was the first media organization arts fusion the the thing that
was unique to me about the LLA artist movement here is that it was all fused together it wasn't just
theater or just film or just photography the muses the musicians the poets the painters all of us
were friends with each other and got to talk across artistic borders you know so it was a kind
of a holistic look that was happening here including how it manifested itself with with
organizations like the gathering and and Dr. LeGon they had blacknostic classes on teaching secret
thoughts and processes about Egypt and and and and uh uh uh they're just all of these different
kinds of things were happening concurrent together in this place you know even when I first came
in this is the 70s when I first came so the 71 when I first came to Los Angeles I they had
places called the Jua that was a collective of all the artists doing hair braiding leather
just creating all different types of things with an African move you know African field to it
then they were 20 some things you know all of us were around our 20s and doing this
and then they also had um um drum classes with master drum teachers you know from from Nigeria
that were teaching drum and dance classes they had co-ops for food growing environments
also collective living environments where they all lived with to you know like like the hippie
movement type thing gathering it was all of that was taking place here when I came here and
this neighborhood had all the top performers you know so like you could have the miracles the
temptations Richard Pryor the rhythm and blues performers this place was just wreaking with
that type of stuff and um that's that's the LA that I came here for it came here and this is the
neighborhood that had it in here and it's part of the reason that I gravitated here because I
first when I moved to Los to Los Angeles I lived close to the school so I lived in Westwood first
and then I lived in Santa Monica and when I was editing my films at night I would drive up the
freeway and get off on crinsha and drive up and down this street because again I'm from New Mexico
so just to smell a barbecue and these big beautiful but women and just the brown skins and just
the smiles the just the whole thing that that I wasn't used to but to see it when I would come here
was just really a blessing so I was while I was editing my film I would always come here
and then go to Santa Monica and then come here just drawn very much here I like like this place
and my aunt lived lived around the corner so they introduced me to the place too but but I thought I
wasn't going to be able conquer California you know the freeway system so I got as close to the
school as possible and I also liked the air in Santa Monica and Westwood because at that time the
air down here was even still bad but in Santa Monica I my eyes didn't water and I you know in Westwood
and those places because I with my eyes being from Arizona in New Mexico was not used to this kind
of smog that was here so I I also stayed there but even there I found out a lot about the history
because just being in my ethnographic brain I always ask about where what and why is of a place
and then also as being a scout in New Mexico we would go all the way to the Indian time so I would
always want to know where are the Indians living here what was that like in this area you know
where and then I remember even you know because I was milk in the military I like reading maps so
the whole thing I was trying to get the LA River you know I was trying to I was like oh cool I'll
be able to kill kill a lot of time hanging around the rivers over here it was like drive across
them and didn't even know I had passed it so that was kind of interesting too so but but it still
made me map the area and made me look at it in another way and then some of my earlier times with
the projects of the community arts program so we worked with the Humanitist project and that was
one of our kind of I guess semi-political projects where we as as artists film media artists worked
with teachers and we worked with the teachers with their from seven o'clock in the morning till
their 12 o'clock class and then we would have history art what else history art and not science
we wanted to integrate science into it but we had about four different
classes that would all collaborate and then we would go out and go and look at the native culture
and then we looked at the Spanish culture and found the whole old Haseyendas and where they were
and then dealt with the map of Los Angeles in the earlier days and then the people and then
do it all the way up until it became westernized and then then looked at the airport systems and
stuff like that were in and around the Los Angeles really dug that kind of way of teaching so we
would help them then present it in a video way and then the kids got to learn a lot about the
native culture they made all of those cross-secting spaces. What's the cross-crest you see with that
kind of work and then what you're describing about sort of what you found sort of early
to the black movement in Los Angeles you're tapping into African history and culture and sort of
finding who you are in the world. Well the thing that was unique about California is once you do
that kind of research it freaks you out because this was a black colon it was colonized by black
Hispanics you know and so that was like how come people don't bring that out you know and then
you find out that all of Ere street is called a Cayada Negroes you know it's so the street of
the blacks and so it's like wow this is pretty deep and it when did that when did that name change
go it was with 1932 so when it was the same time that this place was built you know so so there's
a kind of an interesting history thing that happens here because actually California's history almost
started in the early 30s to me you know because they were switching up and I used to co-teach a class
with Norman Klein and he calls California the history of forgetting. Yeah I was just going to say
there's just so much covering up or saying that there is no history when there's a lot of deep
history so so that was what was unique and so that ended up being my banner of discussing because
my families are black Hispanics you know we're from that kind of stuff so we're Miss Chisos we're all
of what that is about and so to me I wanted to I saw a lot of similarities there I saw us there
you know so that was what I I was digging about the history and then I thought that that should
be brought out more and then that kind of even let's see so that led to in in 84 I also did
another project called electronic cafe and like China cafe was a part of the Olympics and we
connected five disparate communities using what later became the internet you know and so that
was part of how I started working that way too so the whole idea of melding cultures and then
the same thing was happening with me and this this politics and non-politics things so I found
even more than that it's important to do art because the more you do you divide you know so if
you have a Latino culture hooking with the white culture hooking with the black culture hooking
with the Asian culture and then you talk politics that it's like you talk religion it explodes too
but you talk about I might so I'll bring in a core player and then talk about the confluent culture
between between the core and flamenco because they're right across and I was I was saying I know
there must be some kind of cultural connection because they're just a rocker this the ocean from
the sea from each other so there has to be some kind of confluence and then lo and behold when
we're discussing it and working it out with this teleconferencing connection it comes off that the
meningo has a flamenco group you know because it's because the core is a natural thing of a of a
guitar and then the kind of stopping and the movements are all culturally blended so it's just
pretty obvious that those things happen so that was what I started trying to do is define the confluence
of each culture because as African American as African culture you'll find a confluence in every
culture because rhythm foundation of cultures you know we're the old people so so those old people
have have infiltrated all of the various parts of other cultures and so that's the way that I started
dealing with it is it is so in some ways it's like even when I do we're doing projects with China
we find out that there's Africa and China and then the whole Chinese museum will tell you
you know that in fact these things are happening that there is Egyptian influence from the ancient
days of those times and these so each of these things happen so and then that helps both sides
because we then get to see this migration pattern that we talked about Lucy leaving and all
these types of migration patterns and this but we play like it doesn't happen when we talk in real
life and so that's what I found my job is to do is remind people that you know Califa which was a
black Amazon that infatuated a group of guys that were black Omores who were Spaniards who came here
and you know what I'm saying I'm smiling because you know I'm dealing in history this is
the hot thing right now is global history and I was sort of coming back up what else is this
yes yeah so it's just like you're able to kind of like connect those things and even with me I
even I looked I had the book of beginnings you know I looked at the book of beginnings and I looked
at my hometown in New Mexico right I look up the members Indians who are their major influences
the Phoenicians they have Phoenician language you know I'm just like town and you know what the
fuck is this you know that doesn't even get brought up in my history when I was studying in kid you
know but that was in fact something that the book of beginnings and I was like wow so then and then
when I then I read about Hannibal and then being a part of the Phoenicians and then you look into
the wars that the that the that the the Italians had with them and then them attacking Carthage
and wanting to kill the place because those folks found ways to pay them back quicker than they
wanted to and they were saying how the fuck are they able to do it you know I bet you they went
to the Americas to get their goals and they're they're paid back money you know they went to the
gas tax and stuff and came back and he said here's your shit what you know you know and that was
what was coming to me in the sense of there let us say well we got to stop them from and then
then the Roman said we got to stop them from getting the ocean because they're powerful in the ocean
and that's what makes their strength because even when we whip them they still are in the ocean
so they stopped them from doing their ocean travel and then stopped them from coming back to their
home because they disengaged that whole place you know so it's that kind of stuff that I think
that needs to be kind of mentioned as a part of our history and it would make young black kids
feel a little bitter because we're included in the history you know it isn't just like a subnote
because that was my frustration as a kid is like I would get real fascinated about seeing Caesar
but then my ass is getting whipped you know I'm like you know that's not helping me because I can't
dream you know it's always dream within a slave mentality you know and if the Greeks and then
you're just the the painter that's getting your ass with oh then they're too and then Egypt even
in Africa land that no the New Europeans got their ass is whipped by the guys who came from the north
you know so they're just every way that you that you try to find yourself in history being powerful
it gets stomped on you know right and so you saw a way of putting media tools in the hands of
these kids as a way for them to sort of shape where they are yeah to start at least finding out
the definition as I'm finding it out too so we could use this this strong strong medium as a way to
to to to empower yourself and to engage and and and to redefine and like the word that we're
using now rebrand black you know you know to kind of offer that up what I'm doing now okay could I
just ask you to just you know give us the quick story of chaos network okay you know what was
behind it when you got started we talked a little bit about I think but what are the kinds of
things that happened to you today okay so yeah when I started chaos network at then it was video
33 and then we had morphed into chaos network I named it 333 because I thought again it was
kind of the chaos numbers you know it was the pyramid numbers and all that stuff I was playing
around with and so but I initially really just started this place because I wanted to fund myself
outside of Hollywood you know I wanted to figure out how I could live as a media person like a
lawyer does without having to be a cedar signage you know or how how you know I'm not a lawyer but
but a doctor but a lawyer having to do law for the for for the state or something you know they
could do their own private business so I'm going to emulate that concept and then just put my
card in the door say I'm open for business so who am I going to work for it and I say I'm going to
work for the what I now call the poor and the vulnerable and and I and use the medium as a way
to and to build strength with them because they don't have anybody to advocate for them in this
neighborhood you know so I'm going to I'm going to act as an advocate for for the poor and the
vulnerable with this medium and so I started working with all the nonprofits so I says I'll
offer up my skill that I normally be you know work at Columbia Pictures I want to come here and
work in the community with that and so that was how I started really and then they paid me to work
20 hours for myself and then so me and Charles Burnett who who's a fellow filmmaker we we started
working on a script and I wanted to make it I did research and finding that kids from 11 to 25
young people were the most treated the most outside the culture they were treated they weren't
understood a lot by the society and so I thought that that would be a interesting focus for me
because it also is where the new culture grows from is the new dance movements the new feelings
and everything so I said this might be an interesting place because I could do death in the graphic
work and then also use that that like zonial herstance who use it as notes of a culture and then the
and then we can build scripts out of it for dramatic sense because then it can be real as opposed to
so so I said okay let me find out what the kids are who are they you know so put them up and says
what's this hip hop hippity hop stuff that you're talking about what is that about maybe
would break down the words you know fresh means this and you know jamming means something else
and break dancing and all these did just broke out the whole language huh yeah yeah that
that that film was called at first called it new the noobium but people weren't understanding it
so we ended up calling it i-fresh and so and I blended it with the idea of the roster movement so
that was how I was really starting to look at things is so when I was in DC I started looking at
the youth movements because the thing that I was starting to notice with my study of the blues
was it was the young kids that created the blues it was the young kids who created jazz they were
young and they grew old in it you know and so I was like wow that's interesting and it's almost
generational so each of them but it's the same story so but told with different tools you know
the tools of the time period of that and so I saw that rebel you know it's followed it all the way
to them being cut off of the instruments and then saying okay now we're going to research the past
by remixing the all of what was there and so I saw it as remixing and a historical study as opposed
to what a lot of the guys were feeling that all these damn kids are just telling music and they don't
have no music sense and all that but what did you expect if you cut the music out of their world
and so and the most logical thing is is that we have an archive of the best music that ever happened
in the world that's in these records here and so they started going through it and and doing
the great jobs that they were doing and so that was how I would experience the homage and its
historical research and it's all that is really interesting of like you know James Brown's like
he drummers just could see us over yeah and I would even ask some of the kids at first you know
that was how I would deal with them I was like and you guys think you're doing that with the 808
listen to this live beat by James Brown what you know you know the little insulin to these different
guys that have created music and it kind at first they would push back from it then eventually
they would soak it up and I remember the the the the the place for me that I learned that it was a
totally different world was when I loaned them my out well I loaned them one of my albums and they
start scratching the shit and I almost hit the kid you know I was like you're doing what
well I'm going to give it back to you I'm like hell no man I don't have to buy another album I just
don't understand you guys you're tripping you know how are you scratching my album up you know so we
got it like that but then again you know I started understanding and it actually integrated it in
my work I made glitches my scratches you know I started going toward those as a kind of a way to
start it you know dealing with my ideas and so so the the last film that I put together at UCLA
for for me to go out in the world with was well actually there were two films because I went to
ethnographic film studies so my film in that one 1980 I did a thing called Babylon is falling
a visual ritual for peace and what I try what I did with that is I chronicle the interconnection
of the African continent with the new world continent with the old world to kind of show this the
triangular slave trade but then to show how people within the triangular slave trade always
fought back it wasn't just a rollover and beat them up type of thing it was a constant push and
pushback a push and pushback so I just wanted to show that as a part of my thesis of of of
showing it in that way and the other piece that I did around the same time that was a film so
that that Babylon is falling was multimedia it was using every form that you could get from magazines
to slides to whatever anything that had a picture I would use it you know and and use it to tell my
story and then then the other one before that was called the Nubian and the Nubian was was
going to be a precursor to this I fresh and and it's basically the whole idea was
a part of what my ethnographic study was was African religion and so and so I would go to
bimbais and all of those and so I always infuse the idea of spirituality and every of these
pieces that I did which I should probably name the films I've done I and my first film was
Medea and Medea I that wasn't done in 71 and it was didn't have anything to do with Tyler Perry
and but it dealt with the iconography of a mother god figure and so I showed her up against the
desert so it was just following my line of doing these nudes in the desert as an Arizona person
so I did the same thing but I integrated animation which was also a part of my past too so and what
I did was the the teacher who who I worked with at that time was a person that worked with the
smothers brothers and he did Dan McLaughlin and he did the the history of western art in two
minutes you know like did it real fast and I was impressed by that so there's what if I did the
history of African people in like three or four minutes too and to make that all the information
that goes inside this mother figure and then half her give birth and then at the end of that
birth I say a culture provides identity purpose and direction if you know who you are then you
know what your purpose is you know so it was just that kind of a simple poetic and then I had
um then laroid Jones leroid Jones-poimoverd and and it was showing all of our
history and I chant poem saying raise the dead raise the dead niggas raise the dead raise the dead
raise the dead niggas raise the dead raise the dead niggas raise the raise the raise the raise the
raise the raise the raise the men for this time and this race this time for the next race and
that kind of hook in it. So I used that as a kind of a constant chant with them, with
them breathing off through it and then the kind of heartbeat of the baby off through
it too. And then it build up to a crescendo and then go. And then that like that.
So it was fun to do as a, because as a film kid raised in that, that was what I always
wanted was something visual, not talking heads. And so, and then the next piece I did was
call I and I and it dealt with my military life is that I saw it was the first time that
you could kill somebody when you made them the other. So that was the whole idea of I
and I was that we're all the same people in this earth and that things have gotten
straight by the devil or whoever that makes it where it's you and I. And from that point
on, there's been trouble on the world and the world has gone astray. So that's my subtext
to start this story in a journey. And what I was doing at that time was I wanted to fuse.
I was really interested in changing the rhythm patterns of films. To me, films needed to
be infused with what has been called soul and music. Whatever that is that divides our
music that makes it that uniqueness that Michael has. Michael, nobody can do Michael. Stevie
Wunder is Stevie. Nobody can do Stevie. John Coltrane is John Coltrane. Nobody can
touch the soul that he's able to touch and then then Mr. Bird who then thought of centrifugal
breathing as a methodology to have his own space. All those kind of unique ways of dealing
with your art, I think, was what I like about our people. And when you know you're getting
stopped and you say, okay, follow me down this road. Never come up for air. Okay, where's
your air going to come from? And so I think that that kind of stuff is really interesting to
me to see what happens with humans when they get trapped. And that was what I felt like when
NAMM getting trapped like that. And so I felt it, what would it have been like 500 years of that.
And then how does cultures deal with that? And so it was fun kind of etching that kind of stuff
out. So it made me look at different places. And so hip hop was an amalgamation of all of that.
For instance, even the break dancing, for instance, break dancing was Kapuella. And so Kapuella
was a coded dance that was a viciously strong martial art. And that got us our freedom in Brazil.
There wouldn't be any more own societies. There wouldn't have been a lot of the, there wouldn't
have been the Rostas without it. Because they were able to whip ass and go up on the hills and
protect themselves with this magic fighting system. And so I think, and when I read about that,
it was like there's that soul fighting because these cats would watch a horse and watch him get
there's a certain point when they're both all four legs are off the ground. Grab one leg, pull it
from under and have razors on their legs, cut the right of his knife and then disappear behind a
bush all in one fell swoop. That's cowboy and everything else mixed together. You know, because it
and so that kind of fascinated me in the studying of this stuff as we were going through it because
this is the stories you don't get to see. But imagine if we were able to embody that in movies. So
that was what I started thinking. So Charles and I started writing. And so then the, I fresh, the
Nubian was really about young people who have that ancient spirit in them and how does it get activated.
And that they are being activated periodically throughout the movie and sometimes they don't know
and so that's what it's about the first level of the movie. So I was going to make the first movie
like that in the next movie where it becomes even more like a superhero. But to make it go toward
a superhero in time, not the first episode. So that's my next life is to work on this whole series
from the Nubian out and to show it in different places. Like I want to show how some of my life in
Southwest. So when the person travels there, they can meet the Geronimo and interverse with the
thought processes of the real Indians there and how they feel about their life. And between that
Texas and Oklahoma kind of gathering of folks. And so each and then you go to the South, we can
then kind of embody the spirits of the people that were there in New Orleans and the voodoo that's
like my mom was made raised in Texas and they still practice a little bit of that stuff and
believed it in that environment. So that's the other part is the whole migration west, you know,
that has really got looked at too. So all those stories are what I'm wanting to tell is that
western migration because we've has the northern migration from the South, but no one really has
charted our story, you know, and told it in a way that makes it insightful and understanding.
So that's one of the things that I plan on doing.
If you feel like in your story telling to your, I'm just curious how are you responding to
some of the, I get like the black exploitation film, there's some of the more mainstream treatments
of this kind of fighting, fighting that kind of character describing and what you're playing with that.
Yeah, I didn't never like those guys. No, as a matter of fact, when our films get shown in
Europe, they feel proud at us. They say, you guys are the only quiet quiet. This is like jazz,
and that's that was the best thing I ever heard because they were saying that we were following
the tradition of jazz and not kind of not not a aimless and Andy. And to me, most of the work is
aimless and Andy. Yeah. And so yeah, no, I never, now see, it's according to what you call
black exploitation. So that was what the thought to me was, is like some are telling the true story,
like Superfly was a true story. It was written by a black man, directed by black men,
Shaft was the superhero concept. All of the copies are the black exploitation to me. And it's
the same thing with Mr. Sweet Sweetback. That was a true. It had sex, it had craziness and all the
but then to make those then icons that represent us forever. No, that's not us. And so that's the
problem I think with that's what I call black exploitation. Jamah Fennaka, he did the penitentiary
series. I helped him do those things. I don't consider those black exploitation. It was a black
man's rendition of what he saw in that world. But anybody else who emulates that and writes that
as as supposed to be our story, then it becomes a room, you know, that means exploitation to me,
because they're exploiting something that they caused in the first place. You know, that
and I'm not saying they, the artists themselves, but that the society as a whole has caused to
a certain group of people to have to be in shit. And then you see them in shit and then they
make the story about them in shit. And then they tell it in a way that humanizes the whole process
in ways because they found jazz and blues there. And they found something that they were able to
make flowers out of the compost, you know. And I think that's the blessing that we've been blessed
with. And I'm beginning to see that when I'm doing my most recent study, that it really was
planned, you know, by the Egyptians. You know, the Egyptians inculcated the power of the music.
And they put all of their thousands of years of history and icons in our music. And that's the
reason it's extremely powerful, because it's touching on things that we don't need that we're not
aware of yet. And I started noticing that because it's almost our cosmology. You know, it tells
the view, our world view to its umpteenth degree. And any portion of it is like a hologram about
our world in the mathematics, the structure, your cadence, the symbols, all of it is like a hologram.
And you can break it off and it'll answer all the various questions if you need science answer,
you need a cosmology answer, all of them are built already into the music. And I find it out more
recently that that's how Africans are teaching the history, the ones that are enlightened about
their culture, you know, they're teaching it in that manner. And the more interesting thing too is
that they're teaching it, that they're migration. The reason that they had these massive migrations
is for obvious reasons. Alexander the Great, because he wasn't too great for African and Caesar.
You know, those inclusions into Africa caused the great migrations that we're talking about,
you know, from those areas of that world, you know. And so that's the kind of interesting thing.
Anyway, I get all excited about all this stuff.
Could you take us just back to the moment of UCLA and the cohort that you found there
and that community? You alluded to it a little bit.
Yeah, well, what we found was it was first person was highly garrima, highly.
This is the way the school went. It was like when we first went there,
up until the year we started, all the people of color who were going to school there were
considered the other. They were ethnographic. So everything was ethnographic with Asians,
with Middle Easterners, even Yugoslavia, all those kinds of places. They were all considered
the other. And so we all had ethnographic. So there was a ethnographic layer that was still
at the school. And so we came in for the first year of the being the first film students to be a
part of the regular program. So we had that kind of an onus on how people treated us like we were,
some of them were treating us like we were the, you know, what is it that they're still fighting
about us having a privilege because, you know, did we deserve to be their kind of thing, you know,
and you know, have the money to be in this rich school kind of thing. So that whole thing was,
and so it forced us, so nobody wanted to work with us. So highly happened to be the first person
to become a TA at that time. And so we all gathered around highly and says, okay, cool,
if they're going to push us into a corner, then let us all be in the corner together and work
out some ideas. And so we created, so it made us create every grant that the students had,
we won them. And after we won them, they killed them. You know, they would stop the
bare grant. We were getting those 10, 20 grand. And so we were just lining up saying, okay,
it's your turn next. So you go for it. And by the time, by the time we all got, it was our turns,
they all started disappearing, you know. And so we were like, damn, so. But that's the camaraderie
that we had. And it was about 13 of us. And it grew into about 22 of us. And we over 10 years,
we, and we're still doing films and stuff. But for the most part, we were able to create
what, 22 features, no, 55 features and shorts and features, you know. And with-
What did the name come from? The way we're going to go?
It was, yeah, it was put on us by, by, by a man who thought that it would be a good idea.
Because it struck the ears right, you know. So, so that was where they put it. And I hated the name
at first, but I figured, and then I looked up Rebellion and you know what comes up first? Slavery
bellion. If you Google it. So I was like, so maybe that's the way they saw us is people who,
just because we, again, were prideful, we wanted to make our work really represent our people
in a real way. And we use music as our main structure to build from that. Because music was very
free to us, you know. And so we used our structure that. So.
Would you prefer revolutions to rebellion or-
I don't know. I think- Well, what we call ourselves the LA School.
Just straight up. Yeah, that was what we were being called up until it got called Rebellion.
And so- but Rebellion means I think it means that we rebelled against doing black-sploitating films.
And so I think that's an interesting discussion. And so that was something that I'm going to,
they were starting to use that as a mode to discuss that whole era. Because at the same time,
Europe got to see our work. And here in this country, only museums and college,
you got to see our work. But for the most part, it wasn't shown in regular theaters.
And so it was kind of kicked out of the country like jazz was too. And blues too.
You know, it was not very well treated by the populace while it was here. But the people overseas
really saw the beauty in it. Because I'm telling you like my film, when I showed it, they had a
retrospective in Paris, the I and I, I got a standing ovation because the people said it was
a real African film. And why aren't more people doing films that celebrate Africa in a
prideful way? Shirley Clark, the thing that she said after she saw my film at the first
school screen, she was like, how long do you think that you can keep the people who built the
pyramids down? So it's that kind of a thought process that I think our work brings on is just that
it shows the prideful, high cultural sense of our culture. And will you like to carry it with pride?
So now it's moved to...
Well, yeah. So back to maybe two that put it here, starting to show when the police
started to come and start. Okay. Yeah, with the pool, let's see the pop.
I have the group of guys that I started working with here, they're called Project Blode. I started
with them in 84. Yeah, Project Blode. I started with them not in 84. I started them in 92. But in 84,
I started with the group called IFresh. But let's see here with...
I'll say I don't have good busy in here. Let me see. I have one that has all the guys on it.
Get busy.
So let me just do this one right here. This is where I am right now in history. We're doing a project
that we're calling using the Sancophaprincibles. Sancophaprincibles is again the whole idea of
soul. I'm trying to really investigate how the thing that we have to offer up to the world is
the struggle that we went through in life and how we were able to stay healthy and focus culture
on our music. It has a lot to do with our music. It has a lot to do with our idea of having
everything have our innate body but also the spiritual body about it. It was an integral part of
what African thought process even as African Americans. I always use the example of just the
Baptist Church. You can see how black people deal with it and how the Western worked out with it.
You know, just those that's just one of the most dichotomy actions of just how Western.
And then you can say, bump, bump with a horn with the saxophone and then
cold train and bird. How they dealt with that same thing that was in beer music and really
propelled that horn into another level of like emulating a voice and stuff. So I think that's
what we can offer up as technologists is a kind of a blissful blend of spirit with a technological
instrument. And so the first thing that we thought we I had as a was to repurpose payphones.
And so in repurposing them since I was doing this teleconferencing and all those is like,
how can we connect people and then again, how could it take care of the poor and vulnerable.
So the first thought is let's put a Wi-Fi on the payphone. And then if we add Wi-Fi,
then it has a carcass that we could put computer in. And so yeah, that's the that's a part of what
we ended up doing is then it could be a totem, emulate the ancient totem system. But then to
repurpose the original piece itself, we started deconstructing them, tearing them apart, put them
back together, see how you can add a computer into the whole thought process. And so we so about
five, six weeks ago, we put this project together at the School of Innovation. And I'm really also
trying to track teaching my and I really like working in college environments because you can
you get about 20 heads on an idea, you can get a lot more done. And I really like that type of
process. And I'm very open with cultures because I think it's fun to see it in a lot of different
ways. So we have Chinese, we have Chinese students, people from from from from what like
Slovonia and Pakistan and those areas along with folks from you know various parts of the United
States and then blacks and whites and South Africans. Just a lot of just blissful blend of 15
masters at PhD students from USC and the School of Innovation. So we put this together.
And thought of is this like a treasure chest of ideas and concepts. And using the San
Coffit principles and to reclaim your past by going into the future with with pride.
And this the whole wrap again like I was saying is to do this thing for the poor and the
vulnerable is the envision of open face. And so the whole idea of it being open and free
is really enticing to me because I think we can kind of that might be an interesting way for us
to to kind of occupy the virtual space. And so that was what I started thinking is the
occupation occupation of the of the virtual space. And we occupy it with our icons. Then that
iconography could be the things that we work with in the future smartphone sphere. And so if we
already know what the problems are going to be and we have ticket takers that are there for the
things that are virtual then we could make sure that gentrification doesn't happen in the in that
sphere you know in the virtual sphere. So so that's what the thought process was with this and so
how can we do it how can we engage and then to do a class that we can track for 10 years.
And to resist gentrification and see if we can make a sustainable community.
And I use this type of type to show how chaos works is to organize ideas to get concepts together.
And then to set up these these social models the scale up and down so we can replicate the systems
and then to influence the providers and then to encourage artists to really be some of the
major people that engage it on the growing level because if we can engage things when
the artist is involved then I think artists can help a whole lot because most people don't know
how to think like artists. And you're saying get in on the ground floor right because all this is coming
down the pipe. Right. So we can have these as ideas because I already met with MTA and I told them
we have these things and they're like wow so we can help define what they dream toward you know.
If we've already done the dreaming so this is what this workshop was about is to get all the
different people we get over a phone and then we use the Steve Job methodology of quickly thinking
of ideas and user-friendlyness of the objects. So we would do that saying if you plugged it in what
would do? What would you press? How would you act through it and just go through the whole process
and not not just think of something but how it really works. So this was the whole planning part of
it and then the mission like I said was to tack that that monitor I mean the the payphone in front
of my field building here because it was a private own when it isn't owned by Pac Bell. So we could
hack it and get an idea of how to do it and then you know this is to show that it's the first thing
that you normally come and see if you come up and this is what you normally see now.
And so we bought 14 of them from a shopping center and got them from $20 each.
Yeah and they didn't see what need we have. So we're thinking of doing hyper local distribution with
it. So all the wonderful music and arts that are created in film and video and all the things that
are created we can you have to come here to get it. So the forces people to come to a black
community to get the needs kind of like like it did in the past if you wanted to to go to the
black neighborhood you had you know to listen to jazz and love that was it. So we then came up
with our logo and our label we got it as an intercopart and we used Sancophah and also the
Phoenix which are the same kind of concept is regeneration and this is regeneration to Cuban I mean
to Brazilians is to have a piranha eat it and make it something and then here's New York they
made a phone booth into a library and so just to give people ideas of a lot of different ways that
we can attack it and then an aquarium. I want to see that in France and this is San Francisco they
tagged it up and added some vibe to it. And then this is the whole idea of local producing so
this guy made his music where you can only get it at this cafe and then this is the Raspberry
Pris that's the computer interface that you can tie a screen to you can do all kinds of things
with it and of course we want to show documentaries and then see our codes so we're thinking of coming
up with real unusual ones so we could so you could if the person had it on the t-shirt you could aim
the thing at the person or you could show it on a magazine and art and then we're mapping the
cultural density of this area so within the five mile radius of here there isn't a black person
who's famous that didn't live or work around this area and that's really frightening I mean it's
you know you can almost just say anybody you just say it miles Davis dilly holiday
Ella Fitzgerald lived right up the street Hampton Haas Chambers Brothers is just on and on and on
and so we want to bring this out and then we have the new schoolers that I've been working with so
the new schoolers we have that have been out of my place is like the early ones is the guy who
did Lion King he was one of the young kids that we worked with when they were being ostracized and
didn't couldn't have a poem to place so we provide them with that and this is another concept
that we were thinking of is the urban treasure hunt so that makes it where people can go around
with their bicycles or walk and and test out other places and then have coupons that they can
use as a way for that and so this is what I'm saying as an artist we can think of a lot of just
unusual ways for things to happen if we engage the earlier parts of this so that was what I'm
I'm finding as my new world is just to let's do this story banks you know just like people can
come up to it and use Skype tell stories and listen to other stories by sending them to your
smartphone is what we're doing you know so you can and so this is the mapping project that I was
telling you so we're doing the mapping the cultural density of the neighborhood so we can show
that that's the economic engine for this neighborhood and that we need to really bring it up
because we can't act like we're surprised that music our music is worth money anymore you know
so I think we should act like it's worth money so that's that's what I'm doing with this and I
I really just broke this out on saying how booths could be used you know for triggering videos
DJ music you know you drop a quarter in you can see a local business thing you can use it as a
point a tour for an audio tour so it can be used to adults and things so you can go to each one of
these places and so it's just really good for all these different things so and this is the
other part that I started dealing with is just all the different things that it could be used for
which is quite surprising I mean you know how much how stretched out and then this is some of the
kids this just to show the cultural impact I have groups of kids here that that are really cutting
edge in front music so this movement here hasn't been defined yet it's like a blend of hip hop
and punk music and skater and they call it while that's so indie and bananas
and they perform here this is just so and then this these are religious like we had like religious
hip hop church here to where the men who really wanted to praise God but wanted to do it with
like wrapping style they would get around in circle and praise the God like they felt it you know
and it was kind of interesting so for me you know cinema screenings we have these in here
so do you feel like you sort of the cool spaces that you sort of curate this space or yeah
it's an investigation it's an investigative I see it as really a laboratory to testing ideas out
and then lunch launching them out to the world yeah cultural startup yeah and we've been able to
really start up a lot of people in different ways here and so it's just really using the idea
of four walls in a mine and getting the kids together and being positive we're able to almost do
almost anything so I'm able to do one thing after another or have multiple things concurrent
so this is our multiple thing concurrent we came up with an artwork to attack
empty buildings you know there was a lot of desolence and so we looked up stuff and found that
there was a whole idea of fan-themed galleries so we pitched fan-themed galleries and I'm on the
bid so I talked to the owners and said let us be realty company for you and we'll put some art
up in it and and so we we were able to give a major major anchor to come in it was like the
Norton Family Trust where the first people to come through and wanted to get a group of buildings
but we had a little kind of the neighborhood wasn't quite ready for that much strength yet
so but we got to test it out you know got to see that it in fact worked so we were able to fill
nine buildings changed the look of a neighborhood engage the theater next door to make it where it's
upgraded it because it was just a decilent old building with homeless people in front of it
well they spent $12 million to just do the facade you know and so that's the kind of thing
that I'm seeing and then we also are engaging the green world so we put together classes on that
and then to see how artists can do sculptures and design the area and all like that with
the as artists so it's been fun man I just engage it and there's what it you know all the different
ways that you can go just try it out and see what can happen and then that way you can send
out strong strong youth and we also go internationally so one of the things that I did in 99
I took went with a yogi bajan sent a group of black yoga teachers to go to Cuba and he sent them to Cuba
because that was really the place where all of Africans who were in the new world shook off
the middle passage and got reprocess and sent to other places so he felt that there was a whole lot
cultural memory there that we could tap by talking to the Babalaus and so we went and talked to
the Babalaus there and had them talk about the presence of yoga in their culture because yogi
bajan being from Babalaus are like priest in a yoga your book culture and Cuba practices it like
no other place better even than Africa because what they've done is they throw their science in it
so I got to talk to physicists about tribal markings and they're not tribal markings they're you
they're really immunizations you know like acupuncture immunizations with herdenum and so when
you see a whole group of people having it it's just like all of us who yeah we all have our little
mark and but they did it with where they would isolate and focus with tradition with with the
acupuncture points in the culture you know and of course if you ask some of them do they know what it
is they don't because it's thousands and thousands of years of history that just they're just
following it by road you know so but with under the minds of a physicist they look at it and they
wanted to see specifically what you know what's what's up with this and so they were able to really
study that so we were able to talk to them that way I found I I found my trips to Cuba really really
really wonderful because it's the society when it comes to intellectualism and studying of
medicines and stories and arts they've thrown all their money into it you know the people may be
poor but the artists are very rich and the intellectuals are very enriched you know because they can go
as far as they want to and the other thing that was a blessing with that culture to me is that
they had an army of healers they would train healers to go out to go to places not army guys you
know they they didn't ship ship out their arms only to Africa when they needed to fight against
the partite but for the most part and then even that 300,000 soldiers to fight against the partite
that's how many people they sent you know I was really pretty amazed I was like wow no wonder they
were pissed at them that's like I didn't have no idea that they had that many boots on the ground in
South Africa in the southern African Republic so anyway so that was our Cuban trip so I I'll
show you this one this is Los Monuquitos we got to meet them and the thing that was fun about them
is Los Monuquitos are really from New Orleans you know they're a whole group that moved to
New Orleans during the time
music
So this is inside here.
Now this has been a real interesting experience these last 18 years with these guys because
I've watched them go from their 20s to almost 40s something now.
So the whole process of watching hip hop get older and then working with their next generation
of kids has been...
So we ended up being the first group from the US that really worked with the cute
Chcommands.
Were they about to come here as well?
Yeah, they ended up coming here, but over a period of time.
But once they were here, it's just a different thing.
It's different to become an American.
What they ran into was once you become an America,
then a lot of your things like your apartment,
you have to pay your rent, you have to utilities are pretty heavy.
All the things that they had basically paid for by the state's
school you have to pay for.
So I think the thing that I started seeing
is once you kind of ex-off utilities and rent and not having
to pay high price for your food, then you're
almost talking a lot of your wage.
So if you then make about $2 to $300, $400 a month,
that's you don't need that much more.
So it kind of equalizes itself and you don't
have to pay for hospital bills at all.
If you need your teeth done, you just get it done.
And then your kids, they can go to college
as long as they can pass the test.
They can go all the way to PhD as long as they can do it.
So the socialism was really kind of interesting.
It's to me more bureaucratic because they're really hard core
bureaucrats.
So when we had to shoot there, I had to go through so many
levels of communications that it was really.
They were trying to shake me off, I
think, in the sense of the bureaucracy.
And I was more like taking notes.
I'm like, damn.
And I would go to the next place and I would be smiling.
And they were like, why are you smiling?
And I'm like, this is fun.
You guys, you're sending me through all this shit.
It was like, I'm learning.
It's like, now what's the next step after this?
Where do I have to see?
Because I'm excited.
I like your process.
Because it's like, yeah, like DJ, we went to a theater.
I mean, we went to a nightclub.
And we talked to the owner.
But they don't own it because it's owned by the state.
But he said that we could put the DJ in at a certain time
and not knowing that the DJ is part of the state, too.
So we came in and we set up our stuff.
And the owner said, we could do it.
And the guy is like, he doesn't have no right to do this.
And through our shit away and started,
well, it's gotten to a fight with him because we thought,
but it was just when you're in the US, you talk to the owner,
the owner, who else do you talk to?
But there you have to talk to the state.
And so that was a little bit interesting, even for DJs.
So they have everything really organized
to umpteenth the green.
Go ahead.
When you were sending up, you were talking about the Rodney
King decision.
And you know, what it was like being here on the ground.
What was your experience with that?
With Rodney King?
That moment, yeah.
Well, the very first thing that happened was I was,
we all couldn't, we thought that it was definitely
going to be a guilty verdict.
And so, I almost forgot about it.
And so, I got off work and my wife came and got me.
And she told me that Rodney King's guys who beating were
released and were like, what?
And I just rambled throughout the city.
You know, I ran around and then we came here
to our community.
And people were really angry.
This is really, really, really, really angry.
They were befuddled, just running around, just like not
knowing almost what to do, but angry, angry, angry.
And I think the icon for me was to see a young white kid
get off on the corner here and was apologizing to everybody.
And then people were, didn't care.
They were used to him as you know, he pushed out.
And I told him, don't go further south.
I said, don't go further south, man.
He got in, went further south.
So that was really deep.
So I don't know what ever happened to him
that he was candid up in the wrong kind of history
to be in an all-black community.
But I think he had the right attitude
because he was like, I'm sorry, man, even though it isn't
my fault, but I'm sorry, that's the dumbest thing
that this country could ever have done.
And so he dealt with it that way.
So that was one of the icons for me.
But then the next thing was the real paramilitary handling
of it because I just wondered about all the burning.
I am being a military before.
I just know you can't.
Building doesn't level in a couple hours.
It doesn't burn down to a rubble in a few hours.
So I think it would be like even myself,
if I had to strike a fire inside a store and have it burn down,
I wouldn't know how to really do it.
It's a hard thing to burn, see it, and hard floors.
And then to make it where it's so combustible that it burns it
and burns it hard, all the infrastructure and stuff.
Even if you threw gas around, it would just burn mostly
the gas.
It wouldn't burn the whole building that fast.
I just can't see that.
So I was noticing that as a real thing,
it was really kind of strange.
It was cathartic, a lot of people.
And all the whole cultures, it wasn't just the black thing.
It was a lot of people from Central America
out here in the streets.
And they were just this pissed off.
And they were used to war zone.
So they dealt with this pretty easily.
Because I remember I was right here.
And then I saw a couple of little ladies walking out
and I missed all of this.
And I was like, senior Rita, I'm not a very good night
to be doing this.
And she says, son, hello, right?
It's all right.
And then they went down there and I saw them next.
And they had a couple of smirred off containers.
You know, not just the bottles, but just the crates
on top of their head.
And they were taking this shit out.
I was like, OK, go ahead on, y'all.
I was like, so that was the kind of an indication of how
it was just everybody.
It was everybody was pretty pissed.
And everybody took advantage of what was happening there.
And then the following days were even worse.
People just really, there was anarchy.
I had never seen anarchy in full verge.
But it was anarchy people were throwing things
through picture windows and along the way, grabbing shit.
In broad daylight, it was just kicking in things.
And if someone grabbed them and stopped them,
and we would stop them in places where we knew the people
and stuff like that.
But you couldn't do all of them.
But so it was indiscriminate hitting sometimes, just
like just boys being boys, you know, like with a bat
just hitting shit and stuff like that.
I was here guarding it.
But people, for the most part, guarded it for me.
And then we had another incident that was really interesting.
We had a thing called a black gallery
that had almost thousands and thousands of sculptures
in it from Africa and all over the world.
And the building next to it was in fire.
And so everybody came from out of the residential neighborhoods
and pulled them all out in the street and saved this place.
It didn't burn.
But then the following couple of days later,
after they pulled everything, they helped them
pull everything out and then put everything in.
And not one thing was stolen.
No way.
So it was almost like people were almost like a tomatons
drawn towards saving those things.
They just came in and helped him pull out all those things
because the fire looked like it was going to blow out
that building.
So things like that happen.
The Korean family that was on the corner here, who still
is here, they'll pull out a book.
And they say, they have a whole place burning.
This is the black families help me save my place.
It was black people.
So they were proud to let people know that all
of us did because I went by there and they stay off this.
These guys are cool.
And they just leave them alone because the grocery store
that went up the two days before that I saw him just
knock somebody in the chest and say, get out of here.
That kind of stuff just like really kind of evil stuff.
Or you don't do that to a customer.
No matter what kind of customer you grab them and hit them
and stuff like that.
So the Koreans have a short, just like black Americans.
So it was pretty volatile with the two groups here.
And I also had an insight with Koreans
that's different than most people because they were my friends
in Vietnam.
And Koreans are considered the black people of Asia.
And so there is a kind of a, they would say, me, you say, me,
saying, GI, they would deal with us in the same kind
of cultural way that was really respectful and felt
similarity.
So I was telling all the black people here
that they really feel like they're us.
So that's part of the reason they migrated to our neighborhoods
because they also took care of us in Korea
because all the army soldiers and those guys dated them.
And so they knew us in that way.
That's the reason that they're here.
And they know how to braid your hair because they've
created the hair in Korea.
And they know how to take care of black hair and black bodies
and the whole thing, which is kind of unusual.
So they came here with a lot of skills
and were able to undercut our market real well
because it was outside money.
And so that's what I'm learning.
I don't blame things on folks.
I'm more of just like learning.
So that was what even that uprising was about for us
to for me, the police thing that happened a year later
with the police proving trying to prove
that they are powerful like this.
And you know, I must not 100% blame it on the police.
And this is what we ended up studying with it
because I have this friend Marcelina Morgan
that ended up doing a study on that time period for me.
And what she found was it was imitil again.
It was the same thing that killed imitil.
It was us that killed it.
We whispered with this passive aggressive attitude
about like did you see him hunting in around with that white girl
and saying it loud enough so the master could hear it.
And then like what like girl and find out
that it was the grandfather that was hearing it
and then he tells his son and he says,
you know, he's been around all those news
and he's up there doing this.
And so that whisper came up to the point
that it ended up killing a kid.
It's the same thing that happened to us.
They were they were they were cell phones were just coming in.
So in gang banging with our kids and the all head hoods
and they're all men standing on the corner
and you saw how many of them were
is just like a lot of kids.
So we emancipated the street, you know,
that was what we were trying to do
because in the 80s they all got fearful of the street
because there were people who were thinking drive-by's.
But again, that was you know that that's what happened here
was that it was the CIA agents came here to that theater
and said that they caused all of that havoc in our neighborhood.
They announced it saying that it was
because it was a part of the problem.
Imagine kids who don't have sense
like these cars, I mean like the burning down
of these buildings when they don't have that skill.
You know, then the second thing
who has exporting and importing capabilities
from Central America and bringing in crack here.
And they don't have no airplanes,
they don't have any airplane skills, you know,
nobody's bringing it in on the ground.
They're not bringing boats through how does it get here?
Got here through the agents, you know.
And they admitted it.
And so this whole neighborhood when we call
and some of the early studies by the guys
from Martin Luther King, all the doctors,
they were all saying that this whole gang thing was made up.
And I know it's hard to believe,
but the thing that they would say is just this is like,
you look at a gang and you look
all internationally organized they are,
their black churches aren't that well organized.
And it's the most organized thing we have.
And then so how did these kids get all of this organizing
skills all of a sudden?
Out of prison, come on.
You know?
And then the other thing is a military man is shooting, you know?
When they were first killing who they shot at
and both of the people are moving,
you can't transact, you know,
you have to be a super sniper to be moving
and hit a moving object, you know?
And you almost can't even do it with a machine gun.
So those are little things that came out in my brain
and they made me go, oh, that's a little bit different.
So I asked the kids, you know,
and they were shooting, did,
were they trying to hit him?
And they were like, yeah, oh, like,
and they were moving to it?
Oh, wow, that's a little bit deep.
Cause in order to really do that,
you have to shoot thousands and thousands and thousands
of bullets to be able to be that much of a marksman,
marksman, you know?
And they don't have that much money.
So all those things are the things that made me go home.
I don't have an answer for it, but it did make me go home.
I don't know, I don't know what the answer is,
but I know that it's more than just these guys here
in this neighborhood.
Yeah.
Did you feel any of this?
Because it's all my friends?
Did you ever ask?
Of the uprising, no, I didn't.
I was, I, I, at that time viewed it almost like a birth,
you know, I really thought it was like intrusing on people
while they were just getting authority of the energy out.
And it was, it was a time that to me, my,
I know most of my political friends couldn't understand it,
but I'm just not that kind of person.
I don't like shooting.
Cause even homelessness, I, I was asked to do projects on that.
I can't shoot a mother scrambling little ass five hour,
you know, to get her kids fed and find a place to sleep
and in a danky ass downtown in the first place.
And so it just, it doesn't push good buttons in me.
And I don't even work in prisons.
I hate working in prisons because I had a job on doing that
and I just can't last too long when people are in prison.
I can't shoot people like in an animal state of being.
And even if it helps them out of it,
I, I can't put myself in that animal state of being
to, to shoot them in that way.
It's just, and so I, I rather just tell stories about it
cause we will use a prison and tell a story
about a person in prison.
But I, but to shoot a real live person
that has to live through that whole, whole degrading experience
and the document and by high behind bars and stuff.
I've never been able to really do that.
You know what?
So that, that's my kind of foil,
but I am not into doing that.
So that was what, that's what happened with that.
So, but what I ended up doing about it is I did it,
I did do a piece now that I think about it.
I did a piece called Word Sound and Power
and I did it for Channel 28.
And, and so my focus was then to show how powerful art was,
you know, so that art, art places where they only place
not attack, you know, because we have a sense
of working with the community.
And then we made poems out of the stories,
you know, made music out of it.
And so that was how I dealt with it is the whole idea
of how we deal with compost and put flowers in it, you know.
So that was more, again, how I dealt with it.
And it is too nice of a way for some people
because they wanted to see the dirt and grime of it all.
But I tended, I tend not to tackle things that way.
Because even with my story on I and I, that, that piece,
it was about an African-Wing goddess coming to see her people.
So that was what some of my friends would say,
how come she's not dirty?
She's not, what a kind of revolutionary dirty.
I was like, that's not how I, here she's a goddess, you know.
So, but, so that's my differentness.
And I used to always have a fight with a lot of the guys
because even if some of the guys who were
called themselves revolutionaries and they were the lie
on dude like communism, and I would say, I don't like communism.
And they were like, why?
Like, I read the Communist manifesto and it said,
the lumpkin proletariat lives off the state
and that's my mama, you know.
So how am I, you know, they're saying that we're,
that's the nastiness of the earth.
You know, like, well, that's not really,
but I'm like, that's what I read, you know, I don't know,
you know, that you can say that he really didn't mean
your mama, but that's what I read.
You know, and so I don't see what's so good about that system.
And then when I met communist, they were more bureaucratic
and harder and not nice people and they were,
they were very racist themselves.
So I mean, I didn't see what was so good about that whole movement.
So I never aligned with it.
And I have always, like, like I said, I've always,
this has been a presentation of the Library of Congress
and the Smithsonian National Museum
of African American History and Culture.